the individual is handicapped by coming
face to face with a conspiracy so
monstrous that he cannot believe it even
exists anded truth coming at you with
the truth and look where we're at our
nation's capital all the symbolism
behind us all kinds of stuff on the
ceiling I never thought I'd see so much
like just in your face stuff like or
aoris compasses Sun Motif everywhere
even the names of false gods and yet
people think that this country was
founded on Christianity we're about to
show you that's not true here we are
Washington DC the
Obelisk why do we have an obelisk in
America we're going to find
out we have all the evidence needed to
prove to anybody if they'll just look at
the evidence that 911 was an inside job